después de más de 40 días de asedio
mariupol está devastada
el alcalde de la ciudad dice que más de
10.000 civiles han muerto y 120.000 más
están en extrema necesidad
tras nada pensábamos que lo peor era el
bombardeo pero en realidad lo más
aterrador es un tanque no hay nada peor
que un tanque cuando se mueve mientras
estás en el suelo puedes oír como gira
la torreta da mucho miedo no sabes dónde
va a disparar y sus las fuerzas rusas
están asfixiando la ciudad tras rodearla
y avanzar hacia el centro estás imágenes
publicadas por la milicia ucraniana de
azov muestran a los tanques rusos siendo
eliminados en las calles pero otra
brigada que defiende la ciudad la 36 de
marines pintó un panorama sombrío en un
post de facebook el lunes diciendo que
estaban rodeados hoy será probablemente
el último combate ya que la munición se
está agotando será un combate cuerpo a
cuerpo algunos morirán otros serán
capturados no sé lo que pasará después
pero les ruego que se acuerden de los
marines
los separatistas pro rusos afirman
controlar el puerto de mariupol aunque
el alcalde dice que los combates allí
continúan el presidente volodymyr
selenski ha pedido más armas
desgraciadamente no estamos recibiendo
todo lo que necesitamos para acabar
antes con esta guerra para destruir
completamente al enemigo en nuestra
tierra y para cumplir las tareas que son
obvias para cada persona de nuestro
pueblo en particular desbloquear
mariupol
de lenski también advirtió de que rusia
podría estar utilizando armas químicas
en mariupol después de que un
funcionario separatista pareciera
respaldar su uso el lunes